Центр Берліна, площа біля Бранденбурзьких воріт.
Чеченська діаспора в Європі вперше за останній час
вийшла на публічну акцію протесту -
проти, як кажуть самі чеченці, депортацій та античеченської кампанії у ЗМІ.
На плакатах - "депортація як смертний вирок"
і "між Путіним і Кадировим немає різниці".
Привід - публікації в німецьких ЗМІ про зв'язки
вихідців з Чечні з організованою злочинністю.
Останнім часом газети та телебачення дозволяють собі
на адресу чеченців дуже неприємні речі,
які не притаманні чеченському народу. Образи свого роду.
Ми сьогодні вирішили - досить брехати про нас,
вистачить говорити неправду.
Ми вирішили боротися за свої права.
Нас у Європі 300 тисяч людей.
Однак представники берлінської поліції в офіційній відповіді
на запит Deutsche Welle наполягають:
група вихідців з Чечні знайшла свою нішу в злочинному світі Німеччини.
Зловмисники чеченського і загалом північнокавказького походження
є міцною складовою структур організованої злочинності у Берліні.
Через високу готовність до застосування насильства
вони вважаються дуже ефективними в досягненні своїх цілей.
Через історичні, соціальні та геополітичні чинники
злочинці чеченського походження демонструють такий рівень згуртованості,
який незвичний навіть для організованої злочинності.
Результати розслідувань підтверджують те,  що пояснюється історичними причинами:
серед зловмисників чеченського походження вкрай чітко виражено
поняття честі, дуже висока готовність до застосування насильства,
а от повага до державної влади вкрай низька.
У профспілці берлінської поліції підтверджують:
останніми роками вихідці з Північного Кавказу
все частіше потрапляють в поле зору правоохоронних органів.
У серйозних конфліктах, особливо із застосуванням сили,
вони дедалі частіше фігурують в ролі підозрюваних.
Останніми роками і місяцями дещо змінилося.
Раніше чеченці займалися вибиттям грошей з боржників,
рекетом, а тепер більше "кришуванням".
За словами поліцейських, вихідців з Чечні
невипадково багато хто боїться -
навіть у злочинному світі.
Серед чеченців є люди, які мають досвід бойових дій.
Які не соромляться застосовувати зброю:
ножі, пістолети або автомати Калашникова.
Бувають зіткнення, які призводять до масових бійок -
і тут чеченці теж виділяються.
Вони у відмінній формі і добре натреновані.
Володіють технікою єдиноборств.
У нас були випадки, коли двадцять членів арабського клану
були укладені на землю шістьма чеченцями.
Учасники акції в центрі Берліна не відкидають можливості
існування злочинних угруповань, пов'язаних зі своїми співвітчизниками.
Але їх турбує інше:
коли саме слово "чеченець" стає синонімом бандитизму.
Ми говоримо про те, що ми не є ані мафією, ані злочинним угрупованням.
Ми перебуваємо на території Німеччини, де дотримуємося законів,
краще за багатьох інтегруємося,
наші діти вчаться у гімназіях, університетах.
Редакція DW зверталася із запитами з приводу участі
вихідців з Північного Кавказу в структурах організованої злочинності в Німеччині
до генеральної прокуратури Росії, слідчого комітету та МВС.
Наразі жодних відповідей ще немає.